President Yudhoyono: Thank you,
Professor Sachs, for your nice word of
introductions. Excellencies, distinguished
guests, friends, ladies and gentlemen,
thank you, Professor Sachs, for giving
me the opportunity to share with your
distinguished colleagues and guests my
thoughts about the Millennium
Development Goals. One of the most difficult
things to do these days is to say
something important about the Millennium
Development Goals and the problems
of poverty that has not already been said
or written by Professor Sachs. Having
said that, I wish to begin by quoting
a few familiar statistics that are grim enough
to bear repeating any time. Despite the
abundance of the world as a whole,
there are still 1.1 billion people living
in extreme poverty.
Nearly 3 billion live on less than $2
a day. Some 1.3 billion people have no
access to clean water. Three billion have
no sanitation. Two billion have no
access to electricity and close to one
billion entered the twenty-first century
unable to read or write. But the most
startling statistic is the number of people
who die every year because they are too
poor to live: eight million, enough to
populate a sizable national capital. It
is said that statistics do not bleed, but
when
they are as horrible as this you have
to pause and think. And apart from that
when you see those video clips on TV of
skeletal babies in the throes of helpless
hunger your humanity is challenged.
You cannot avert your eyes. Attention
must be paid; actions must be taken. And
yet it took many years and many major
U.N. conferences and summits before the
world community found a way of taking
concrete actions. At the millennium
summit of September 2000, in New York,
the heads of state and representatives
of 189 governments finally adopted the
Millennium Declaration and its agenda for
development. That agenda, called the Millennium
Development Goals, are
actually all about human development and
how the human race would make a
journey out of poverty. Much has happened
since then. What the (Inaudible)
deprecated as just another U.N. declaration
turned out to be far from being just
business as usual.
We knew how serious was the U.N. system
on this matter when the Secretary
General set up the Millennium Project
and had it chaired by Professor Sachs to
help countries towards their MDGs. U.N.
agencies and other multilateral
institutions have given top priority to
helping countries attain their MDGs. Many
governments have successfully integrated
MDG target into national development
planning and public investment strategies.
But there is a great deal of global
(inaudible) today's massive effort. Financial
flows for development are
insufficient and are moreover often flowing
in the wrong directions. We do not
have an international trading regime that
can effectively open up markets for the
exports of developing countries.
Some developed countries that can make
a real difference between success and
failure in this grand endeavor do not
have a genuine sense of partnership with
the developing world. In the Asia Pacific
region it can be said that there has
been real progress towards the achievement
of the goals. Alongside their robust
economic growth that took place in some
countries, the region has sounds of the
fastest-growing economies in the world
with high domestic saving and plenty of
international results. Yet the promise
of the MDGs remains out of the reach of
millions. Many countries in the region
lack the institutional capacity to take
appropriate action towards these goals.
They have limited capacity to deliver
efficiently and equitably the basic services
needed to improve the overall quality
of life of their people.
Those, despite a dramatically reduction
of poverty, the region is still home to
more than 700 million people languishing
in extreme destitution. That is about 70
percent of the world's poor. Malnutrition
persists among 400 million people in the
Asia Pacific. Two of every three Asians
have no access to safe drinking water.
Of every two Asians, one has no access
to adequate sanitation facilities. And
this is the region to which the 21st century
is supposed to belong. Women and
children, especially in the rural areas,
are still often overlooked. They should
now have access to basic healthcare, education
and economic resources.
Pockets of poverty that are the result
of uneven progress should be identified and
acted upon instead of being concealed
in national aggregations. This is exactly
what the leaders of Asian and Africa countries
agreed to do when they met in
Jakarta, Indonesia in April of last year,
the first time the Asia African conference
was held since 1955. This time around
they issued the declarations of the new
Asian African Strategic partnership, where
they agreed among others to meet
internationally agreed targets and goals
in poverty eradication, development and
growth while emphasizing the importance
of cooperation with all regions. The
declarations of the regional ministerial
meeting on MDGs in the Asia Pacific held
in Jakarta early last month also recognized
these challenges.
The meeting emphasized the need for collective
action while acknowledging that
attainment of the MDGs is still the primary
responsibility of individual countries.
The ministers proposed (inaudible) regional
cooperation and partnership for
achieving the MDGs in the region with
special attention to the needs of least-
developed countries, land-locked developing
countries and small island
developing countries. We in the region
remain firmly committed and determined
to attain our MDGs. We are mobilizing
regional resources and initiatives such as
the Asian Development Bank and the Associations
of Southeast Asian Nations,
to help us towards those goals.
We have sought the assistance of international
financial institutions and
multilateral development agencies such
as the UNDB. We have invited the
United Nations system to provide comprehensive
and coherent programs of
support for regional countries. Specifically
we have called on the United Nation
Economic and Social Commission for Asia
and the Pacific to help us formulate a
road map to guide our future effort as
we move towards 2015. We urgently need
that road map. The drive towards the MDGs
has turned out to be a complex
journey with many obstacles. Though the
MDGs were formulated to help all
societies, they do not serve as a formula
for progress that applies to all. There is
great diversity among developing countries.
They are not affected by the same problems
in the same way. They cannot have
uniform priorities. In the first place,
there are many factors and combination of
factors that may have to do with the poverty
of nations. This includes a country's
peculiar geography, its climate, the prevalence
of disease and natural (inaudible).
There are also political factors, such
as the lingering effect of oppressive and
exploitative colonial rule, the debilitating
consequences of corruption, the
negligent of government and the devastation
of (inaudible) armed conflict. Every
national strategy for development must
therefore be tailored to the environment
of the country, to its culture and tradition
as well as to its unique resources or
lack of resources.
And let us never lose sight of the close
relationship between development and
security, as has been mentioned by Professor
Sachs. I am convinced that the
struggle for world peace and security
will never been won unless the challenge of
poverty has been defeated. I do not have
to look too far to find a case that
demonstrates that truism. For decades
the Indonesian province of Aceh
smoldered in resentment. You know Aceh.
Aceh is the province in Indonesia
that was hit by the tsunami that cost
130,000 lives. Again, for decades the
Indonesian province of Aceh smoldered
in resentment at what it perceived as an
unfair selling of the revenues from its
wealth of natural resources.
For lack of development the proud and
courageous people of Aceh felt that they
were poor and did not deserve it. Poverty
was robbing them of their dignity.
Grievance and resentment eventually broke
out into rebellion and separatisms.
The result was three decades of armed
conflict. And while the conflict was
raging and taking a heavy toll of human
life, the province became even more
impoverished. The situation became a vicious
cycle: poverty bred violence and
the reign of violence rendered the people
even poorer. In the (inaudible) reform
movement that was launched in the midst
of the crisis of 1998, the government of
Indonesia failed to address the problems
of Aceh through dialogue and
reconciliation. It was not an easy task.
Their first attempt aboard the government
of Indonesia and the (inaudible)
movement to achieve peace through negotiation
was a failure. Then came an
act of God, the earthquake and tsunami
of last December that visited tragedy
upon the province. The unprecedented catastrophe
killed more, as I have said,
130,000 people died and about 120,000
missing in Aceh alone. And it
devastated of 500 kilometers stretch a
coastline. More than half a million lost
their homes. It is amazing how tragedy
can make people see more clearly the
situation they are in. Both the government
and the free Aceh movement saw that
the reconstruction and rehabilitation
of the province could only be carried out
successfully in an atmosphere of peace.
And the only way to peace is to make peace.
We made that peace in record time
and that peace is holding. The challenge
now is to make that peace endure so
that it will become the environment of
a battle in which former adversaries will
be
fighting on the same side the battle against
poverty. Today the reconstruction
and rehabilitation of Aceh is being carried
out in a way that can serve as model
for development planning for the rest
of Indonesia. A master plan was prepared
with the full participations of the people
or of the communities being rebuilt. The
implementations of projects are monitored
and evaluated by the people. Thus
the people feel that they are the owners
of their own recovery. At the same time
we have put in place an airtight system
that guaranteed transparency and
accountability and the disbursement of
funds.
I believe that by doing so we have been
able to eliminate one formidable ally of
poverty: corruption. It was in the spirit
of reform that we were able to address
with any success the challenges of (inaudible)
and development. It has been the
same spirit of reform that we have been
addressing the challenge of national
security and national development since
mid-1998. Where there are grievances
we bring justice and (inaudible) and reconciliation.
We are fostering interfaith
dialogue with the intentions of encouraging
religious leaders and scholars to take
a frontline position in the (inaudible).
Right after this session I will be attending
the interfaith dialogue that they will
be attending by world leaders and hosted by
President Arroyo of the Philippines.
Indonesia also hosted many occasions of
the interfaith dialogue because this is
very important for Indonesia as a diverse
country that we have to bring harmony,
respect others to at the end achieve true
peace in Indonesia. Where there is a
development project to be carried out
we shift the involvement of the largest
possible (inaudible) of (inaudible) orders.
On the long term we are investing
heavily in human development, as reflected
in our budgetary outlay of education
and health. We have in place an economic
strategy that is basically pro growth
and pro poor. That strategy entails strengthening
of the export sector, promoting
domestic and foreign direct investment
to create jobs and accelerating the
development of rural economies.
We are putting new emphasis on rural infrastructure.
Nothing is too small to
matter. A bridge that can cut by half
a day a farmer's trek to town, a schoolhouse
where there was none for miles around,
this makes a world of difference in the
villages. In the face of the skyrocketing
of oil prices we are exercising fiscal
restraint and budgetary discipline. At
the same time we are putting in place a
social safety net to protect our poor
from the rigors of these hard times especially
when we allow fuel prices to rise to market
level. The national social net will
consist of undertaking a human resources
development, infrastructural building
and of course food security. Initially,
we expect to spend 1.9 billion for this effort
to help and to protect the poor because
of the new government policy to increase
the price of the fuel.
The pockets of poverty in Indonesia are
considerable. We will neither deny nor
conceal these through deceptive aggregate
statistics, nor will we give into
despair. For we have a vision of ourselves
becoming a people that have
conquered poverty as the basic problem
of the human condition. We see
ourselves today as a people who have suffered
much but in the process gain a
wealth of experience and insight. In the
current debate on fighting global poverty
the developing countries have argued that
the developed world are not doing
enough to help developing countries. In
turn, the developed world suggests that
the developing countries are not doing
enough to help themselves. Well, I think
they are both right.
Each of us, the developed and developing
world, needs to do more if we are to
tackle global poverty through global cooperation.
We in Indonesia know to
address the ills of our society we need
to improve government, fight corruption,
have better planning, invest more in our
education and health, and utilize our
resources efficiently. Unless we do this
with the seriousness that we deserve,
international cooperation alone will not
be sufficient. In the struggle for
development we know what works and what
does not work. We know what it
takes to attain prosperity, and that is
the continuing refinement of our institution
and human development in an environment
of democracy. We believe in the
perfectibility of our democracy and in
the fruitfulness of our constant process of
reform. That is our fighting fit and our
battle cry. Ladies and gentlemen, thank
you for your kind attention.